we've entered a realm right there's a
universe this is like a planet this is
one of the ways to do it turns out it's
the best way right there even claiming
it's the only really good way but once
you've done that think now what follows
right we talked about what a country is
and why we have them it's rooted in this
gift of speech that we have right we
always have them we're always going to
have laws and the laws are always built
on some agreement what we call yesterday
the final cause of the nation and the
final cause of our nation makes the
people strong whereas the final cause of
an absolute monarchy or any strong
monarchy makes the eldest son of the
oldest and strongest family powerful so
if the sovereign is the strongest thing
then the sovereign is also the most
dangerous thing it's the thing that can
get everything out of balance
get all power unto itself so all men are
created equal therefore they may be
governed only with their consent
therefore the majority will be sovereign
and therefore the majority will be the
most dangerous thing right that they be
sovereign necessary that they be
sovereign but dangerous so you got that
we're living on that planet right we're
not on Jupiter where the gods pick the
sovereign and we're not on Mars where
the Warriors pick that's actually better
than I intended to be when I started
the loveliest one we're on earth and on
earth human beings all are created equal
each of us consent the majority will
rule so now after that the $64,000
question is we know who the sovereign is
how's the sovereign going to operate in
relation to the government how are we
going to set that up and how do they
answer that question where do they put
the sovereign in the garden light
Christian they put it as the voter of
people who then become ones Republic and
that means and this is the thing that
Madison says in the 63rd Federalists
which we read yesterday that Madison
says is unique nobody ever thought of
this one before we're gonna put the
sovereign outside and that means they
can't get out of hand harder for them to
get it they're in control harder for
them to become oppressive of others the
first check the Constitution is a set of
checks and balances which Madison argues
is written in the nature of things and
if you think about it we've been saying
that two-year-olds or so start talking
and dogs don't write and that's just a
fact that's how it is well this is a
fact how it is the same way you know if
you give somebody absolute power over
you and that person is any other living
person I've ever met except my wife and
my closest friends they're likely to
abuse that power right and of course
marriages and friendships operate on a
small scale politics operates among
people who don't know each other very
well and they're people and they have
needs and they see the world through
their own eyes and not through
everybody's eyes they're not divine
beings even if they're divine like you
see so keep them out
but let them vote now we're in an
amazing situation because all the power
is out here and it can be delegated in a
variety of ways into a variety of people
to do a variety of kinds of tasks and
the delegation can even happen at
different times our powers are separated
and eat